my wife and i were classmates in
business school she's sitting right
there we were
both you know when we were in business
school this is a long time ago 1979 to
81.
uh in india india had just begun to open
up to
the advent of multinationals coming in
to build a lot of businesses there some
had stayed on over the years
and had changed their ownership model
nestle was one of those unilever was
another one others had left when the
indian government wasn't as
conducive to foreign investment as it is
in the period in between and so when we
were graduating multinational
corporations like nestle like unilever
were places to work in of great
attraction they were
terrific for
learning the business they were great
for understanding the culture of a
company that operated across the world
they were great for comprehending the
concept of high quality products of high
ethics and how you worked and all of us
looked up to those companies as where
you wanted to be because you would learn
the things that you needed to learn in
your early years of working life and we
guys unlike you all who work and then
come to business school we didn't we
used to go those days straight from
undergrad to business school we were
very young i was 21 years old when i
finished my business school career and
so when you think about that
it you think about the people in that
frame of mind nestle was a very
attractive learning place with lots of
strengths and attributes that i still
think the company has that's how i ended
up there getting in was not easy because
everybody in the in the class would
apply for these few jobs that were
available and they were very competitive
the really attractive part about tesla
was that you were able to move in
different parts of the company very
quickly it was part of why i went there
it's part of what i've tried to build
with all the recruitment programs we run
here as well as in citigroup when i had
a chance to influence the kind of
program is i try and build the chance
for people to go across the company in
different places geographically
functionally opportunity wise so that
they don't get stuck on where they're
joined is where they're going to be and
i think that's a big part of what nestle
did for me it took me into sales that
took me into marketing it took me into
factories it took me into product
management took me into running a region
and gave me the chance to work on
changing the entire inventory system of
the indian company to manage inventory
and working capital better things that i
don't know that a lot of our companies
would have given me that breadth and
depth of knowledge